>>> WE HAVE A CNN EXCLUSIVE WILL
THIS MORNING, A STUNNING
ALLEGATION FROM THE HOUSE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE SAYING THE
TOP ETHICS ATTORNEY IN THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE URGED THE KEY
WITNESS TO GIVE MISINFORMATION.
SOURCES SAY THEY URGED CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TO SAY SHE DIDN'T
RECALL PARTS OF HER TESTIMONY.
HE TOLD HER TO AVOID TOPICS THAT
WOULD CAST A BAD LIGHT ON TRUMP
URGING HER QUOTE, NO NO, WE
DON'T WANT TO GO THERE.
HERE WITH THE EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING IS CNN'S PAULA REED.
PAULA, WE SAW THIS IN THE
SUMMARY THAT THE COMMITTEE
RELEASED AND THERE WAS
SPECULATION ABOUT WHO THIS
PERSON WAS AND NOW WE LEARNED
MORE ABOUT IT.
>> Reporter: EXACTLY.
THE COMMITTEE DID NOT IDENTIFY
THEM, BUT CNN LEARNED THAT
STEPHAN PASSATINO IS THE ETHICS
ATTORNEY WHO ADVISED HIS CLIENT,
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, TO SAY SHE
DIDN'T REMEMBER THINGS SHE DID.
IN A STATEMENT TO CNN, HE SAID
HE DIDN'T ADVICE CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TO MISLEAD THE
COMMITTEE.
HE SAID, QUOTE, I REPRESENTED
HER HONORABLY, ETHICALLY WITH
HER INTERESTS AS SHE
COMMUNICATED THEM TO ME.
BEFORE HER PUBLIC TESTIMONY,
HUTCHINSON DROPPED HIM AND GOT A
NEW LAWYER.
THIS IS ONE INCIDENT OF THE
COMMITTEE SAYING TRUMP TRIED TO
OBSTRUCT THE ORGANIZATION.
>> WHAT ARE WE EXPECTING THE
FULL REPORT TO LOOK LIKE WHEN
IT'S RELEASED TODAY?
>> Reporter: IN ADDITION TO
RELEASING THE COMPREHENSIVE
FINAL REPORT, THE COMMITTEE IS
ALSO EXPECTED TO RELEASE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE INTERVIEWS IT
CONDUCTED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THERE IS PRETTY MUCH ONE THING
PEOPLE ON ALL SIDES OF THIS THAT
THEY ALL AGREE ON, THEY WANT TO
SEE THE TRANSCRIPTS.
A SOURCE TELLS CNN THAT JACK
SMITH SENT A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS MONTH
REQUESTING ALL THE INFORMATION
FROM THIS INVESTIGATION.
WE'VE LEARNED THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN SENDING DOCUMENTS AND
TRANSCRIPTS IN THE LAST WEEK
FOCUSSING ON EVIDENCE RELATED TO
JOHN EASTMAN AND MARK MEADOWS.
INTERESTINGLY, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ALSO HAS MARK
MEADOWS' TEXT MESSAGES THAT
PROVIDED SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE SO FAR.
BUT TALKING TO THE TRUMP LEGAL
TEAM THEY WANT TO SEE THE
TRANSCRIPTS ALSO SAYING THEY
BELIEVE THERE WAS TESTIMONY THAT
UNDERCUTS THE PUBLIC NARRATIVE.
THE COMMITTEE TELLING CNN
THEY'LL RELEASED HUNDREDS OF
TRANSCRIPTS BUT SOME WITNESSES
THEY'VE VOWED TO PROTECT.
>> PAULA, YOU'RE AN ATTORNEY,
RIGHT?
>> Reporter: RECOVERING, YES.
>> YOU HEAR PEOPLE IN
DEPOSITIONS AND THE COURTS
ASKING, SAYING I DON'T RECALL,
CONSTANTLY SAYING I DON'T
RECALL.
IS IT UNETHICAL TO ADVISE
SOMEONE TO SAY I DON'T RECALL.
BECAUSE YOU HEAR IT ALL THE TIME
AND YOU KNOW THEY DO RECALL.
>> HERE THE PROBLEM IS IT
APPEARS THAT THEY HAD A
CONVERSATION AND HE KNEW SHE DID
RECALL THINGS.
SO IF YOU INTENTIONALLY ADVISE A
CLIENT TO MISLEAD THE COMMITTEE,
THAT'S PLAYING AT THE EDGES OF
WHAT IS ETHICALLY SOUND.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS PART OF A
LARGER PATTERN THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO SET UP,
ARGUING PEOPLE IN TRUMP'S ORBIT
WERE TRYING TO DISRUPT THE
INVESTIGATION.
SO THAT'S REALLY PUSHING THE
BOUNDS.
>> WE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE
LEGAL SYSTEM OVER THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS SINCE THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN OFFICE.
>> PAULA REED, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.